now listen to me all right your arm I
just found your Armenians
I'm Armenian yeah I love it yeah know
what kind of just say something
no yeah I'm gonna anyway um I was in
Israel mmm with Steve Byrne oh and Lopez
and we were like walking down the street
now you got where is this where you got
your career from you're just kissing
bunch okay right and they were like this
is the street where the Armenian
Genocide happened right and I thought I
cried me and Steve Byrne cried but when
I meet when I when I run into you I
don't cry like I don't want that what do
you think yeah I mean I feel right bad
about the atrocities that happen yes
thank you for recognizing many ins like
you yeah right
I wasn't me like me like me I showered
good guy clean when a man looking good
you're a good guy is what a very rude
man but it was a Turkish it took you
guys yeah I don't know there wasn't a
street yeah do you and shame atop don't
get along you can't go in the lift to
bring me to where the gents I doubt you
know see him a Tosh yeah she's a Turkish
she yeah I'm gonna get along yeah I'm
sure I'm sure Jews talked to some
Germans once in a while many people that
work there at the many people people oh
this would be a good one I can feel it
because another thing too is like you oh
you're always sour at me man never dog
no I I have like adjacent chibok go oh
yeah he's really mad you don't even talk
don't say hi to me dog you ghost me all
the time
okay sweets a couple weeks ago about how
you ghosted yeah you just go I'm not a
distant I'm old
okay I don't know Surrey slang yeah
alright so let's be looks like an emoji
you should go [ __ ] three back alright
so let me say this all right what is
close to me that means were you just
like oh yeah I'm gonna do this all let's
hang out they are just never reply yeah
why do i why oh don't be gonna be great
I can't wait like cross on me I go to
write you deceive me oh right I only
ghost when people to see all right when
I see deception or shadowplay going on
right I don't play you Armenian folk I
love it yeah okay but let me just say
something oh yeah who's shy shady ones
like yourself yeah and you do shadow
play yeah it's like you you you you lie
with them there's no army shadow play
dragon we never do that shows verbal
black magic oh yeah right and I see
through it okay that's why I don't show
up to your function that's not true
rapid what's the story this is what I
hear
first of all I did this pocket I did
your guys podcast right you know never
do that no no I'm gonna though it's the
intention but there it is there it is Oh
actually show up that guy right but I
did another one what was the other one I
did punch drug love yeah punch drunk
right who with me into you the other one
that the lady today the fight nanny
what's her name
Candice Candice yeah yes so I did that
yes so I thought I already did it
I think you're like just no no no dude
this was beat you ghost me before that
no just a let's go let's go to the this
little latest ghost how many well we're
gonna go through the history of the
go-go's are we talking ghosting number
three or number two Oh cuz there's
number one I'm gonna tell but we're
talking number you would eat your
ghosting yeah I think I love ghost
stories this is ghost or no ghost tiger
if you wanna war let's have a war okay
see this one were to say to you okay
then you say to go to do the other
podcast right and I go it's I wake up I
thought it was gonna be at the Comedy
Store so you don't deceive me that one
you have show up you went to the wrong
place he didn't wrongly play I didn't
leave out I didn't leave the house I
would have Skyped in if I knew he had
all this we could Skype you in yeah but
let me just say this okay
that's my bad realize I was my bad so
that's my bad okay
[Music]